[Music]
hold on this video is sponsored by
weights and biases weights and biases is
your one-stop shop for all your machine
learning needs it will track your
experiments with a single line of code
they'll upload automatically all your
logs all your configurations everything
to your cloud it will automatically grab
all the output all the metrics all the
configurations of your experiments and
store that in one neat location so you
can see your experiments you can track
them wherever they run you can compare
among the experiments but you can go
further you can then tune your hyper
parameters according to the results of
those experiments and all of this is
done automatically in a distributed way
you can literally sit on your toilet on
your smartphone and tune your
hyperparameters and start new
experiments but it's not only experiment
tracking and hyperparameter tuning
weights and biases has tools for the
entire pipeline of machine learning
research from the initial idea up until
the deployment and beyond that when you
actually want to track what you've
deployed weights and biases has cool
methods to track all of your data set
and their dependencies to each other as
well as your models and all kinds of
other artifacts that you might produce
they're very powerful visualizations for
all the inputs and outputs of your
pipelines as well as the models
themselves all of this runs in the cloud
but if you're concerned about privacy
there are options to self-host the
system is free for personal use and for
academics and they have great plans for
enterprises small teams large teams
doesn't matter so thank you very much
weights and biases for sponsoring this
video if you don't know them yet
absolutely check them out it's free
it'll make your life a whole lot easier
now let's get into the video
[Music]
welcome welcome to ml news let's dive
into our first story a group of
researchers based in switzerland have
trained city which is a french language
model this is a model based on gpt j
it's a six billion parameter model that
is a language model in french the
headline is write french without
speaking french which is pretty much a
recipe of how i passed high school so
the cool thing about this is that it can
do the tasks that you're used to from
things like gpt3 but with a special
focus on french so it achieves a better
perplexity on french text than gpt3
apparently lower toxicity whatever that
means is better at translating from and
to french and it's better at various
other nlp tasks out of the box now if
you don't know what city means seti is
this little thing that french people put
at the bottom of some of their letters
also some other languages as i am being
told but it's just quite annoying
because you never know where on the
keyboard it is so being quite annoying
seems like a great name for a french
language model the cool thing is not
only is the model open source you can
download a checkpoint the code is open
source but also you can play with it
directly in the browser there's a little
app and there are a bunch of prompts
that are already built in for example
classification of some stuff like what
is fedex fedex is logistics company that
is correct amazon is an e-commerce and
technology company that is all correct
now my french is limited to be honest
i think it means i lost my baguette and
i'm very sad the model says mim
explica only i i don't have a logical
explanation for why i lost my baguette
is it maybe i forgot my baguette i don't
know well in any case it's a french
language model you get it what is
interesting is that among the parameters
it says that a german one is coming soon
so keep an eye out for that
facebook ai on their blog says the first
ever multi-lingual model to win wmt
beating out bilingual models so wmt is
this yearly competition essentially to
do machine translation this is a corpus
of data sets but then also every year
the competition hosts human expert
translators that rate the translations
of the machine translation systems so
the machines aren't able to hyper
optimize on the data sets but really
have to please the humans now first
thing why is this in the ar vr category
i don't know in any case it's quite
remarkable because one would think that
given that all the tasks are bilingual
that bilingual models that can be
tailored to one specific language pair
would be ahead right here but as
facebook ai shows because multilingual
models can ingest essentially much more
data into them so the french english
translations are also informed by the
german data that comes in and because
it's able to make use of so much more
data it can in the end outperform models
that have been trained for particular
language pairs now multilinguality is
not the only thing that's good about
this model the machine translation
community has over the years accrued
various tricks such as back translation
to make use of monolingual data
ensembling and so on so this is really
an engineering effort but it's cool to
see this overlap point where for the
first time ever a single multilingual
model is better than many many bilingual
models and that's excellent not only
because it's higher performing but it
also means that it provides us easier
access to work with languages that have
very low resources that maybe are only
spoken by a very small amount of people
or that have no written form at all like
swiss german for example so excellent
development there is a paper the code is
available and if you want to learn all
the tricks give it a read
view is a new search engine that has
been launched by richard socker
previously the head of ai at salesforce
and this is supposed to be a direct
competitor to the google search engine u
advertises itself as the private search
engine that summarizes the web for you
so there's two promises here privacy and
summarization in whatever form they say
it helps you get things done get news
check github compose a tweet all from
your search engine for whatever reason
you want to compose a tweet from your
search engine but there you go there's a
big emphasis on privacy you can choose
between a personalized or a truly
private experience u.com never sells
your data to advertisers and also they
promise no ad targeting now actually
when you sign up the first thing that
they want to make you do is install an
extension if i click this button it
leads me straight into the chrome web
store so i'm gonna take this with a
grain of salt right here someone
promises me privacy no targeting and so
on uh
no unless this is provably the case i'm
not going to trust any of those promises
so the second big selling point is this
summarize the web and i was intrigued by
that like how is this search engine
gonna summarize the web for me this
sounds really cool so i tried out a
bunch of things like okay they said i
could check news for example all right
news let me zoom out a little bit here
so the interface that you gives you is
this kind of grouped interface so there
are web results on top right here there
is a section for news and then there are
various of these sub categories right
here but honestly i don't see any
summarization like any summarize the web
for me so let me search for something i
would like to have summarized abraham
lincoln and the civil war no it just
gives me the wikipedia page and a bunch
of web results and a bunch of reddit
results and a bunch of these quick facts
right here now one thing seems to be
these uh shortcuts these apps right here
so there are various apps for example
the quick facts app which we have down
here or i guess the wikipedia app which
is up here so the search engine seems to
be such that other developers can come
in and write apps for it so you can
install apps in your search engine and
those will take up one of these bars as
you can see there are apps for archive
walmart all kinds of things there's also
one for github but i haven't seen yet
this uh summarize what was lincoln's
role in the civil war again i just get a
bunch of search results i don't see
exactly how summarized the web should be
anything like this so i was also
exploring a bit of different features
right here for example compose a tweet
so i tried this previously it actually
told me to sign into twitter so
apparently you can write tweets from
here how to sort a list in python now
this gets into a little bit more
interesting things they have plugins for
a stack overflow and also w3schools so
they show the results from these sites
in quite nice cards with snippets and so
on for stack overflow there's also a
sidebar which for some reason doesn't
show up right now there's also this code
completion engine right here so i
entered how to sort a list of strings in
python and it gives me a bunch of code
completion that are apparently generated
by some sort of uh code model i mean
that's fine so i've tried a bunch of
things with this search engine but i
really haven't seen this summarize the
web for you in any particular way this
seems to be a search engine where other
people can write apps for it and then
it'll probably send your search query to
those apps and the apps can give you
useful results now honestly it seems
like a big benefit for sort of like the
big websites right here for example
w3schools is integrated prominently as
you can see tutorials point is
integrated prominently coursera stack
overflow this is specifically for code
but if you look at the other apps that
exists it's essentially all the big
websites so i'm not sure if i actually
want this in a search engine i generally
want the most relevant things and i
don't necessarily want the relevant
things from the biggest sites while i
see the potential of integrating all of
these things into my search engine is
not that useful honestly how many heads
does a hydra have i quite like this
shortcut right here so this little g it
brings you to this website that you
might have heard of but this is also a
pretty good search engine and it
generally gives me the stuff i'm looking
for that being said u is public now and
it is in beta so you know give it a
little slack until it's really full out
and maybe this concept of having many
apps integrate into your searches
provided by other people and not all by
the same company will be something for
the future who knows
deepmind releases open source arnheim a
learnable visual grammar for generating
paintings so bouncing off of the success
of people experimenting with clip models
such as vqgan plus clip or clip guided
diffusion or any of these models that
generate stunning images by using clip
deepmind has done something a little bit
different namely instead of using again
or a diffusion they are using a what
they call a visual grammar so you're
able to give some primitives to the
model of how it can compose an image and
then it will use that in order to please
clip in order to do clip guided image
generation so one application of this is
for example here you give the model a
grammar of brush strokes so you tell it
that it can do some brush strokes in
some various ways various colors various
thicknesses and so on you give a bunch
of optimization parameters and it can
generate pictures from textual
descriptions it looks pretty cool i have
to say and it has some nice controllable
parameters here you can see the
evolution of such a picture as it
develops over time you can see that the
model refines on how exactly it lays its
brush strokes until it reaches a final
conclusion photorealistic chicken
so the code is available along with two
collabs where you can try it out for
yourself and oriole vinyls has tweeted
out this picture right here of young
lacan made up entirely of mnist digits
so the model here hasn't gotten
brushstrokes as option to perform
drawings but just mnis digits in various
colors and you know it looks pretty
sweet so check out paper and code and
blog post and give it a try
wired right this company tapped ai for
its website and landed in court so this
is an article about a company that is
being sued because its website does not
conform to the accessibility standards
of the w3c consortium the company in
question is called ibobs and it used
this other company called accessibility
to make its site more accessible now if
you make a website you can do that with
various frameworks but in order to make
it accessible to for example visually
impaired people you need to annotate the
various parts of your website with their
meaning you give alt text to images you
define an order of focus for example in
forms they should all be navigateable by
your keyboard by using the tab key for
example autocomplete should work and so
on and so on now there are already many
tools to help you with that but it's
still a very very high workload for
developers to ship out websites that are
also accessible to all the people that
want to use them so this company
accessibility says that it can simplify
the work of making websites accessible
to people with impaired vision or other
challenges by replacing a costly manual
process with an automated
state-of-the-art ai technology however
this technology doesn't seem to be
working all that well in all cases which
is something you could expect right so
this whole article doesn't only detail
this case but it says it's a growing
trend in recent years companies use
these ai softwares to make their
websites more accessible these don't
work really well that makes the websites
worse for visually impaired people
compared to when manual labor is used to
do the same thing and so on noteworthy
the guidelines that you have to comply
with is more than a hundred pages when
printed it includes such things as all
text for images and video clear use of
contrast and color ensuring that
features like forms and menus are
navigable using only keyboard without
the use of a mouse or finger and so on
now safe to say this is a difficult
problem right of course ai solutions are
going to be largely subpar when it comes
to this compared to really dedicated
humans doing this however they're
probably going to be better than just
the developers doing it on the side as
they're coding the website under time
pressure and they're certainly going to
be better than nothing at all like i get
it the web sucks for visually impaired
people interacting with a medium that is
this visual when your visuals don't work
is bad it's it's a bad experience and it
largens the divide between people who
have good vision and people who have
poor vision i get this and they also get
that we want to make an effort as a
society to include visually impaired
people more to make websites more
accessible and so on but i don't see
when the standard has become that unless
a solution works a hundred percent of
the time a lawsuit should be filed like
surely having a crappy ai annotated
website for visually impaired people is
better than not having an annotated
website at all on the other hand that
you can absolutely see that if we as a
society decide well just use the ai tool
for this then companies are going to opt
for that and actually avoid putting in
the work of making websites really
accessible so it is a hard problem and i
don't have the clear answer for this but
i would certainly say that ai technology
can help it's better than nothing it
gives you sort of a lower bound on
accessibility on a website even if there
are some mistakes because humans make
mistakes too but here is what i find
funny there is apparently a document a
sort of petition where researchers and
companies and so on can put their name
to ask other people to ask other
companies not to use these ai tools it
says signers include contributor to w3c
guidelines and employees at microsoft
apple and google automated detection and
repair of accessibility problems is not
reliable enough to bring a site into
compliance the document says accusing
some vendors of deceptive marketing and
here it comes the site was started by
carl groves founder of the accessibility
consultancy tenant.io who provided a
withering 35-page analysis of
accessibility's software to murphy's
lawsuit against ibobs so ibobs company
being sued they used accessories
software and now this tenant.ai carl
groves has written a 35 page analysis of
this software prof said he surveyed a
total of about 1 000 pages from 50
websites using the startup that's
accessories technology and found a
median of 2 300 violations of w3c
guidelines for each site here it comes
grove says that this is a significant
undercount because most of the
guidelines can only be checked by an
expert manual analysis so wait did i
understand this correctly did you
analyze 1 000 websites and you either
automatically or by a non-expert humans
figured out a lower bound on the number
of violations to the standards and
that's not actually the standards but
it's a lower bound and therefore it's
better than nothing at all really you
did that and you provide that as
evidence into a lawsuit hypocrite
hypocrite hypocrite hypocrite hypocrite
hypocrite in his report to accessibility
growth site and an image of a model
wearing a white dress for sale on an
e-commerce site the alternative text
provided apparently generated by
accessories technology was grass nature
and summer oh no an anecdote wow and
there you have it the true story here is
that complaining is easier than doing
and we'll always be able to write
articles about ai systems that don't
work 100 yet as i said i don't have the
definite solution to this problem it is
a hard problem it's a balance between
pushing technology and making it
accessible to all the people there are
but how funny that's all i'm gonna say
[Music]
pandaily reports alibaba domo academy
creates world's largest ai pre-training
model with parameters far exceeding
google and microsoft right so this is
about a model called m6 by alibaba domo
academy and the parameter count in these
models is 1 trillion to 10 trillion for
exceeding the trillion level model
previously released by google and
microsoft becoming the world's largest
ai pre-training model so i found another
article by info q right here which i had
to translate from chinese so m6 stands
for multi-modality to multi-modality
mega transformer m6 that's why it's
called m6 and the whole article is like
an homage to chinese research the real
thing that's hailed here as a
breakthrough is the efficiency by which
people can train these models but the
parameter count is a little bit tricky
because this model uses a mixture of
expert architecture which we can assume
maybe to be sparse and therefore a
sparse model with a trillion parameters
is not necessarily better than a dense
model with 900 billion parameters given
that the network is only activated
sparsely at this point we don't exactly
know what we know is that the model is
multimodal which means it processes
images it processes text and so on one
of the invention highlighted by the
article is what they call grouped
mixture of experts or what they call
expert prototyping they say it's so that
different groups of mixtures of experts
can increase the expression space of the
model without changing the parameter
scale no idea what that means so they
tout that it can create more high
resolution pictures like dali can create
fashion as you see here can create
textual descriptions find similar images
and so on alibaba achieved efficient
training of the trillion m6 model with
only 480 v100 cards reducing energy
consumption by more than 80 and the
efficiency is increased by nearly 11
times all right so this seems to be the
real achievement right here the
investigation into efficient model
training as i said we don't exactly have
better data right now at least i wasn't
able to find it what is a bit deceptive
is that the title says that the model
has 10 times the number of neurons as
humans so apparently it has what a
trillion parameters and the human brain
has 86 billion neurons yet of course the
number of neurons is not equal to the
number of parameters for that you need
the synapses in the brain which are more
than 125 trillion so no your parameter
count is not larger than human parameter
count quite yet and even if we get there
it's probably not going to perform as
well as humans just because you have
that many parameters if you people
figure out any more about this model
link it down below in the comments let
me know the scale and design of these
models are amazing this looks like a
manifesto to the gradual growth of many
chinese ai research organizations yeah
do they kick your butt if you don't
write this in you this is like
there's a guy in the corner being like
this is great isn't it
isn't it excellent journalism everyone
on tech writes amd announces the
instinct mi 200 accelerator family so
this is amd's newest incursion into the
gpu space they say they can connect
whatever they learn from building cpus
and gpus together and i honestly don't
understand many of the things that are
said right here or what's supposed to be
special so as far as i can understand it
one thing that's special is that their
machines have like one memory for the
cpus and the gpus which eliminates the
need of shipping data back and forth
which is one of the main bottlenecks in
applications when using gpus maybe i'm
wrong another thing is that the
individual parts that you can put
together into bigger parts into bigger
servers they are connected using super
duper fast whatever connections instead
of pci connections which makes things
yet even faster so for their biggest
servers they have 95.7 teraflops of
floating point 32 matrix operations and
if you go to fp16 they have 383
teraflops i'm being told that's a really
good thing i have no idea but if you're
interested in this if you maybe want to
buy one get in touch with amd please
sponsor me
the state of the eye report 2021 is out
this is produced by ai investors nathan
beneitch and ian hogarth so actually
it's october 12th so this thing has been
out for a while but forgive me for only
reporting on this right now so as it
says these two people are investors so
they naturally have a distinct look onto
the field which is interesting right so
it's divided into various sections like
research trends it does quite a good job
of summarizing sort of what's going on
currently in research where talent is in
which countries at which universities
and so on notably china seems to be
rising quite a bit in pumping out ai
graduates as you can see right here now
it's a quite a lengthy presentation but
what's really interesting is their
predictions for the next 12 months for
example transformers replace recurrent
networks to learn world models with
which rl agents surpass human
performance in large and rich game
environments that's quite a specific
prediction but could actually be true
right small transformers and cnn hybrid
models match current state of the art on
imagenet top 1 accuracy with 10 times
fewer parameters a new agi focused
research company is formed with
significant backing and a roadmap that's
focused on a sector vertical eg
developer tools for life science well i
guess them being investors they can just
make that happen and then claim their
prediction was correct but it's pretty
cool i'm excited to follow which ones
will actually work out and where they
are completely wrong probably they're
under-betting most of these things quite
a bit but you know that's just my
opinion if you're interested in the more
general report as i said it's quite
interesting carries together a lot of
data into a neat little package
techcrunch writes landing ai brings in
57 million us dollars for its machine
learning operations tools so landing ai
is a company started by andrew ing and
has just raised 57 million dollars to
build essentially an ml ops platform
they're doing what they're calling data
centric ai and whole idea is that things
like convolutional neural networks or in
general machine learning models they're
as easy to build as downloading a bit of
code from github and running it on your
data set so the real challenge nowadays
is really to get the data set to a
quality where you can actually train
some good model on it so their product
is essentially this data manager and
data labeler tool where it helps
professionals really label the data this
is all geared towards manufacturing so
here you'd label cracks or dents or
whatnot in
newly manufactured phones and then you
train your model on very little data and
that's then supposed to give you a nice
detector for classifying further
manufacturing defects so their idea
isn't necessarily to build one big model
that's gonna solve all the problems but
to provide the different industry
players in manufacturing with the tools
to build their own models from very
little but very high quality data so
they can essentially get their expertise
into these models i guess that's not a
dumb idea if you're a manufacturer maybe
you want to try landing lens
another startup that has raised a lot of
money is cerebros raising 250 million us
dollars for an over 4 billion us dollar
valuation so cerebros builds these
really big chips that are geared
specifically towards ai computation now
as i said before i've no clue what's
going on in these chip manufacturing
processes and what's important and
whatnot but these are apparently really
really big chips and everything's
connected to everything in memory super
fast and memories with the compute and
yada yada yada what you need to know is
that there are indeed other players than
nvidia or amd in the space of providing
compute solutions for ai and that's a
good thing and maybe at some point
cerebrus will come away from their giant
chips and actually also make consumer
products who knows if that happens it's
going to be good for all of us and if
they stay in the big chip server world i
think it's still good for us because all
of the cloud compute might get cheaper
because there's just more competition
[Music]
speaking of cheap synced rights
microsoft india proposes varuna a
scalable and low cost training of
massive deep learning model system so
this is essentially an engineering paper
that details how you can train big
models on cheap and unreliable hardware
so the system uses both data parallelism
as well as model pipelining so you split
up your data batches across different
machines you also split up your models
across different machines and if you do
that in a smart way you can achieve
actual big throughput so usually big
models have to be trained on what they
call hyper clusters which means clusters
that have very fast interconnect because
in order to do something like an oil
reduce if you have to do layer
normalization or batch normalization i
don't remember which one it is sometimes
you need to send data around sometimes
you need to send gradients around and
that costs a lot of compute and
bandwidth and so on so it's very
interesting to see that these
researchers are able to compete with
these big hyper cluster training
procedures and essentially bring that
down to a heterogeneous clusters of spot
instances that can die at any time so
it's cool to see that ai training of
these big models becomes something like
a kubernetes cluster where you can just
add machines and the system will
reconfigure itself to make optimal use
of the machines however fast they may be
connected and however long they might be
up so if you're looking for a cheap way
to train a 200 billion parameter model
then this might be the way to go
okay here is a shout out to a few places
so the first shout out is to laura
ruiz's website where she replicates a
bunch of things in janla calls and
others papers called learning in high
dimension always amounts to
extrapolation now it's a very technical
paper and laura does a great job here
not only replicating the experiments in
here but providing really nice
background and reasons and also the code
that she uses to do everything so i just
thought this was really neat uh
interleaving plots code math and so on
and really going through all of this and
in the end actually being able to
reproduce the plots of the papers yippee
there it is so beautiful very reproduced
much similar if you want to follow laura
definitely check out our website or
github this is absolutely beautiful
photo laura good job
all right another cool project is real
life punch out by ian charnes this is a
really well made video about using body
tracking models and pairing them up with
punch out the n64 game so you can
actually play this in the browser it
tracks your arms and you can punch using
various boxing moves and play punch out
not only that but ian actually went
ahead and bought many cartridges of the
game as you can see in the background
right here and if you play it in the
browser it will actually use one of
those cartridges because using just a
rom downloaded from the internet would
violate the licensing agreements so
every game you play is essentially
corresponding to a real-life cartridge
as i said the video is done extremely
well it's a fun video to watch or if you
simply want to try it out you can go to
ian's website and just play it by
yourself nothing to install runs in the
browser excellent
alright so this is the section where i
provide some helpful things first
helpful thing market tech post writes
google ai introduces go emotions an nlp
data set for fine-grained emotion
classification i've actually shown this
in last week's weights and biases ad if
you have followed the weights and biases
ads but this is a data set where reddit
comments are annotated with one of i
believe 28 different emotions contained
in the comments it's not only one
emotion per comment but technically any
emotion could or could not appear in any
comment in total there are 58 000 reddit
comments classified into anno it's 27
emotion categories 12 positive 11
negative four ambiguous and one neutral
wait that adds up to uh 28. i was right
so the dataset creation process detailed
here is detailing how they went about it
how they went about balancing the data
paying attention to the fact that reddit
isn't exactly a good replica of the
entire world and so on if you're
interested you can give this article a
read you can also look at the paper that
goes along with the data set and you can
use the data set if you want to try out
your hand at emotion detection i have to
say it's gotten a bit tired to see nlp
tutorials always doing sort of semantic
classification where it's just positive
or negative and this might just provide
a little bit of a more challenging task
pair has this language interpretability
tool it's open source and it's for
visualizing and understanding nlp models
this provides various things you can
look at embedding spaces of nlp tasks it
can analyze things like classification
regression looking at attention heads
analyzing parts of the input which parts
are important for which things and so on
all in all it's quite a rich tool and i
encourage you to check it out if you're
into language interpretability or if you
want to just check out how your models
do the things they're doing code is
available tool is available okay last
week we've reported on rudely the
russian dali model and now apparently
the large model is available for
download as one reddit comment says or
much rather the edit of the comment says
that the availability is on december 1st
so expect that soon yi machine on
twitter says after a year in dev i'm
happy to release the core of my vtuber
apps now vtubers are special sort of
things that i have never really touched
on but this seems to be a large
community that transforms their body
movements onto digital anime avatars as
you can see right here so this also uses
body pose tracking and apparently also
face tracking in order to make your
avatar do as you're doing the code is
available and it's not only sort of for
face and upper body but you can also
track your entire body movements and map
them on to characters as you can see
right here it can do facial point
tracking such that it really uh
replicates your facial expressions so
there's never been a better time to
become a v tuber check out kalidokit on
github if you're interested
[Music]
an article by news file corporation on
yahoo finance that writes that
artificial intelligence now makes it
possible for investors to find promising
new hidden gem meme tokens
automatically this isn't necessarily
what you think you think well there's a
company that tells me which meme tokens
are good so i can buy it no no no no no
see this is an actual token itself so
you put money into the token and then
the token selects projects in which the
money is to be invested these projects
it says are automatically selected using
a special ai based sniper bot so the ai
will look at all the meme tokens the doj
and the shiba inu and the squid game
tokens and they will predict which ones
will go up and then it will take all the
money that is invested into the finu
token put it into those tokens and then
pay out the winnings to the holders of
the finu token i mean look at this for
an enhanced version of this graphic
please yes i want an enhanced version
oh wow that's enhanced that that is that
is so hands absolutely apparently there
is a website for this and it says vote
for fino help the price pump and in the
back there is a dose
okay people who want to make a quick
buck using meme tokens that have
absolutely no value whatsoever are
encouraged to
buy a meme token
excellent now i'm not saying this can't
be done meme tokens are essentially like
fashion there's no reason why this
particular that particular fashion
should be in or out next year and yet it
still happens and there might be ways to
predict it but still whether or not this
is the way to go
uh
can't tell
so i've mentioned this shoe does not
exist last week but there's also this
sneaker does not exist look at that and
this is pretty cool so there's a grid of
ai generated sneakers you can click on
one right and then you can apparently
edit that sneaker so you can go normal
to futuristic you can go high creativity
that's very creative you can change up
the colors a little bit very cool very
functional look at that one
yeah futuristic
creative
light color i mean it's not super
futuristic but yeah so shout out to this
sneaker does not exist dot com check it
out and that was already it for this
week's ml news i hope you had fun hit
subscribe if you liked it we're only 105
million 900 000 subscribers behind
pewdiepie we can totally catch him if we
really do our jobs tell three people
they're gonna tell three people it's
gonna be fine see you next monday bye
[Music]
you